وهذه هي الصوره حسب الاوضاع الميدانيه اما
فعليا نتنياهو حسب ما قلت لك انه يجري
تقييما امنيا جديدا الان وهو سوف يقوم
بالرد على اطلاق الصواريخ الى القدس لان
بالنسبه لاسرائيل اطلاق الصواريخ الى
القدس هو خط احمر وسوف يتم الرد عليه بشكل
قوي
وكبير وهذا هو الوضع حاليا على ما يبدو ان
هدوء حذر الان في مستوطنات الغلاف قبل
قليل كان هناك ايضا رشقات صاروخيه اطلقت
من القطاع الى مستوطنات الغلاف ايضا
القوات الاسرائيليه
وفعليا
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قامت
باستهداف عدد من المواقع التابعه للجهاد
الاسلامي خاصه في الجنوب قطاع غزه
ويعني نتحدث عن من هدنه محتمله الى حرب
محت مله والى تصعيد اكبر ممكن ان نراه
ونشاهد ونشاهده في الساعات القريبه
القادمه هل ما زالت الطائرات تحلقات هذه
اللحظه الان بحسب متابعتك وما تسمعينها
الان
صحيح الطائرات ما زالت يعني تحلق فوق سماء
قطاع غزه كان هناك قبل دقائق فقط اطلاق
فعليا الطائرات او السلاح الجو الحربي
الاسرائيلي قام بقصف عدد مواقع جنوب
القطاع قبل ذلك كان هناك قصف ايضا شمال
القطاع اين تحدث عن استهداف مواقع عديده
من شمال قطاع غزه حتى جنوب قطاع غزه وسوف
نشهد تصعيد اكبر على ما يبدو ورد يعني
كبير ومعقد وكثيف لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات